[Musique]
avec avant de donner un logement à une
famille à une femme qui attend un enfant
ou à une mère célibataire on demande une
feuille de salaire
n'est-il pas vrai que Damien le nombre
d'enfants confié à l'aide à l'enfance
augmente nous en raison d'absence
d'amour maternel mais pour des raisons
sociales
comme on peut donc imaginer que par
manque de logement des enfants soient
arrachés à leurs parents alors que dans
la seule région parisienne plus de 100
000 logements sont libres
le droit est une construction
historique sociale et politique et le
fait de le faire découvrir par la
lecture de grand texte ici dans le
Parlement c'est je crois une manière
pour le Sénat de jouer son rôle et de
participer à cet événement que la nuit
du droit un événement auquel nous tenons
beaucoup
c'est une bonne manière d'informer
justement sur le droit sur la place
qu'on a aussi dans la politique et notre
place de citoyens et je trouve qu'il y a
des choses qui résonnent aussi
aujourd'hui alors qu'il y a des discours
qui date de 1940 même d'avant avec
Victor Hugo et pourtant ça résonne
encore aujourd'hui
très intéressant d'avoir fait venir des
comédiens parce que justement on avait
plus cette sensation vraiment de
d'entendre le texte comme si c'était la
première fois qu'il était resté
qui m'a plu le plus dans cette nuit
c'était le texte sur l'avortement parce
que je trouve que c'est un sujet qui est
très actuel en ce moment et donc c'est
important de revenir à la base de
comment ça a été légalisé en France
messieurs
la cupidité de la clémence est le plus
beau spectacle qu'on puisse donner aux
hommes
mais ici la clémence n'est pas
l'imprudence la clémence et la sagesse
ce que vous devez à la France
c'est que la France attend de vous c'est
l'avenir apaisé
[Applaudissements]